darüber spreche ich mit jemandem der
sich bestens auskennt mit Professor
Andreas heinemann-grüder von der
Universität Bonn guten Abend guten Abend
wir sehen diese Bilder auch aus dem
russischen Parlament das ist ja ein
recht förmlicher Schritt gleichzeitig
verzeichnet die Ukraine geländegewinde
genau in den Regionen die man da
annektiert hat wie ist das zu bewerten
also auf der einen Seite wird jetzt die
Gesetzgebung ausgedehnt auf diese vier
annektierten Gebiete damit kommen auch
neue Abgeordnete in die Duma und in den
Föderationsrat ohne dass da überhaupt
Wahlen stattgefunden haben sondern es
werden die Statthalter die Militär
Gouverneure praktisch dann zu
Volksvertretern auch in Moskau miteinand
das ist das eine die Gesetzgebung die
Mobilisierung das wirkt sich jetzt aus
letztlich ist immer noch nicht geklärt
was sind eigentlich die Außengrenzen
dieser vier Gebiete denn es wurde
nachgefragt und das ist ja in dem
Bestand zum Zeitpunkt des Beitritts zur
Föderation ist damit gemeint der
militärische Status Quo oder der
juristische unklar
sie sprechen da was an was Kreml
Sprecher pestov auch heute gesagt hat in
zwei dieser Teilgebiete will man auf die
Grenzen von 2014 auf diese Front
Verläufe zurückgreifen in den anderen
sagt pesskow dort wäre man eben noch ja
in Diskussion darüber bleiben wo dann
der Grenzverlauf ist wie absurd ist das
dass ein Parlament diese Annexion
beschließt wenn gar nicht klar ist wo
diese Grenzen verlaufen
das ist in der Tat absurd und man weiß
dann auch nicht wo dann eigentlich die
Selbstverteidigung Russlands künftig
stattfinden soll weil die sagen ja das
wäre jetzt Staatsterritorium Russlands
und sie wurden dann auch mit allen
Mitteln sozusagen auf die Verletzungen
ihrer eigenen Grenzen reagieren das ist
im Fluss und ist eigentlich auch
wiederum nur Ausdruck dessen wie hast
dich das vorbereitet worden ist das ist
sozusagen ein
Verzweiflungsschritt war um die
Initiative wieder zu ergreifen nachdem
die ukrainische Offensive sie ja sehr
zurückgedrängt hat da auch moralisch nun
erleben wir ja gerade auch in den
letzten 24 48 Stunden Meldungen das
ukrainische Städte zurückerobert werden
die Ukraine auch wieder Geländegewinne
verzeichnen
entblößt sich da eigentlich Putins
Propaganda auf dem Schlachtfeld selbst
ja sie entblößt sich also es werden
natürlich jetzt die ganzen
Schwachstellen aus systematisch
ausgenutzt die sich schon seit dem
Anfang dieser Gegenoffensive zeigen das
heißt es gibt Probleme dem Nachschub es
gibt zum Teil auch mit den
Kommandoposten also den generellen die
da für die Front zuständig sind Abstände
bis zu 100 km das heißt auch das diese
Kommunikations mal Distanz wird da von
den Ukrainern ausgenutzt auf der anderen
Seite muss man natürlich auch sagen
die Ukrainer machen Fortschritte aber
sie machen auch erhebliche Verluste und
wir müssen uns auch dessen bewusst sein
dass selbst wenn die russischen Zahlen
nicht unabhängig überprüft werden können
und sie liegen bei mehreren hundert
Toten pro Tag in der Ukraine es können
die Russen auch nicht exakt überprüfen
aber wir dürfen nicht davon ausgehen
dass die Ukraine nicht auch personell
sehr geschwächt werden durch die nach
wie vor massive gegenwärterrassen
wichtiger Punkt
den Blicken noch mal auf die Rede heute
des russischen Außenministers lavrov
eben vor der Duma er hat dort den USA
vorgeworfen eine Politik zu führen gegen
Russland eine gegen Russland gerichtete
Politik wie sie einst Hitler gegen die
Sowjetunion geführt habe und dort zeigen
wir Ihnen noch mal ein Ausschnitt den
wir dann besprechen
in dem Russland der unprovozierten
Aggression gegenüber der Ukraine
beschuldigt wird
behauptet die USA heuchlerisch dass wir
angeblich die vermeintlichen Drohungen
nutzen um unseren Angriff auf das
Nachbarland zurechtfertigen das
angeblich auf dem Weg der Demokratie sei
aber jetzt kommen die Stunde der
Wahrheit wie reagieren nicht auf
erfundene Bedrohung entfernen Ländern
wir verteidigen unsere Grenzen unserer
Heimat unser ganzes Volk vom realen
Genozid organisiert durch die Nachkommen
und Anhänger der Nazischergen die sich
dem übersee-herren an dienen heute hat
die USA sich praktisch den ganzen
kollektiven Westen unterworfen ihn dazu
mobilisiert die Ukraine in ein Werkzeug
des Krieges gegen Russland zu verwandeln
ja Lavra 4 mit Vorwürfen gegen die USA
bei mir ist weiter Professor Andreas
heinemann-grüder bereitet der russische
Außenminister hier verbal vor das
Russland weiter eskaliert weil man
bedroht sei
also es richtet sich hauptsächlich an
das eigene Publikum man
wiederbelebt eigentlich alte sowjetische
Feindbilder gegen den Westen als
fundamentalkonflikt wie zu kalten Zeiten
des Kalten Krieges oder selbst während
der Kubakrise das heißt also es wird
hier eigentlich die Ukraine gar nicht
mehr bekämpft sondern man führt einen
Krieg gegen den Westen insgesamt da wird
auf alte Ideologien rekuriert
letztlich hat das aber damit auch ein
extrem gefährlichen Charakter weil die
Auseinandersetzungen als global
angesehen wird dann aber auch dass sie
sagen naja die Amerikaner oder laforf
sagt die Amerikaner haben ja Vietnam und
aiti und Panama und so weiter ihre
eigenen Irak Libyen und jetzt haben wir
quasi ja auch das Recht dazu sozusagen
selber Völkerrecht zu brechen also
völlig von der Hand zu weisen
ich würde sagen dass es natürlich Fehler
der USA gegeben hat aber das so ein
bisschen wie wenn man zum Nachbarn sagt
du hast vergewaltigt und jetzt habe ich
auch mal die Möglichkeit zu
vergewaltigen also das sogenannte whatte
bautisten wo man einerseits moralisch
argumentiert sich aber andererseits
hinter den moralischen Vergehen
sozusagen
seines Gegenübers auch versteckt also es
ist einerseits moralisierend
andererseits rein zynisch
rein zynisch dennoch eine auch weitere
Eskalation immer wieder und
unverhohlener wird auch mit dem Einsatz
von Atomwaffen ja gedroht sehen sie
eigentlich noch jetzt Schritte das Ganze
zu deeskalieren
also eine Form der deskalation ist
natürlich glaubwürdige Abschreckung das
heißt also dass wenn man nicht sich
einschüchtern lässt sondern sagt wenn
ihr mit dieser Option in der Taten
militärisch
hantiert oder das überlegt dann werden
die Reaktionen so sein dass sie für euch
auch ähm
Zweitschlag bedeuten oder dass sie so
schmerzhaft sind dass ihr besser davon
Abstand haltet also das muss
rausgenommen werden aus dem Repertoire
indem man deutlich macht wir haben hier
rote Linien und diese roten Linien sind
auch nicht verhandelbar
vielen Dank Prof Andreas
heinemann-grüder von der
friedrich-wilhelmshelms-universität Bonn
eben zu diesen weiteren
eskalationsschritten auch Russlands
herzlichen Dank